un projet concocté par janette bertrand
on est très heureux elle est là en
direct avec nous elle va nous en parler
bonjour janette bertrand joue plus ce
roi vous allez bien connais très bien
car je suis dans un projet très bien et
s'il faut ça que j'ai voulu communiquer
mon enthousiasme à cupidon possible bon
avant de jouer on va parler en long et
en large de votre projet mais juste à
voir comment vous vivez ce confinement
là depuis maintenant quoi cinq semaines
oui mais j'étais qu'on finit mois par la
turquie ue pendant dix mois
laso sanatorium dans une chambre à
coucher
alors qu'on finance je connais et je
m'en suis sorti très bien alors j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir je pense que et on va
s'en sortir
ça va bien et les convives pour la
situation des personnes âgées dans les
sièges à celle des dans les résidences
je présume évidemment vous êtes très
comme tous ceux qui constatent qui se
passe êtes vous aussi révoltés en partie
non je suis pas surprise
je suis peu surprise pour une chose
celui des personnes âgées
ils ont du recul -6 95 ans et j'ai
beaucoup vécu tout ça de choses et je
sais que dans une société comme la nôtre
la société de performance où les jeunes
ont toute la place eh ben les vieux on
les jette comme le toaster qu'on ne fait
plus réparer mais qu'on jette et qu'on
remplace j'ai un fils de 60 ans qui
s'est fait dire on peut pas te garder
parce que les jeunes comme ils ne
veulent pas veulent pas de dieu ils
veulent déjà alors je suis pas surprise
que les vieux ne on nous en sommes
j'aime dans les séances hnd dans l'est
on nous jette on ne sort que nous parce
que on ne produit plus dans une société
de consommation il faut produire et
quand tu produis tu sers à rien alors on
se sentent éloignés
on est parti et puis on s'en occupe plus
on se dit qu port comme on devrait s'en
occuper c'est l'associé
consommation c'est elle que cherche un
bouc émissaire
ben c'est la société consommation et
cette société qu'il faut changer et au
québec notamment parce que les chiffres
le montrent
qu'est ce que ça vous dit qu on place
beaucoup plus au québec qu'ailleurs au
canada si on veut se comparer là avec
nos voisins 18% le taux de placement au
québec par rapport à à 6 % des
résidences
ça ne me surprend pas du tout parce que
les écoutes et moi on ne me demande avec
toute l'expérience que j ai mon rôle
apparaît trop vieille à vont mourir à
quelques années box et c'est moi qui est
obligé de faire des projets parce que
sinon moi qui qui qui est une
travailleuse dit qu'il ya des choses à
donner
ben alors je profite finalement du
confinement des gens pour dire on va
écrire une autobiographie
bon ceci des yeux et on laisse sa trace
bon ben justement parlez moi de ça c'est
un projet fort intéressant
bon vous avez enseigné longtemps
l'écriture 20 ans ce que vous faites
et là vous allez le faire de façon
virtuelle vous le faites de façon
virtuelle avec des capsules comment ça
fonctionne et c'est destiné active
janette bertrand à tout le monde
non surtout aux personnes âgées qui ont
des chocas c'est pas 40 ans qu'on écrit
çà çà çà dit on les préfère encore
vraiment maintenant au milieu et à kehl
et si on a 30 ans de plus que nos
parents qui nous reste en cinq ans alors
il s'étrangle à aller on a des choses à
dire
alors moi je veux que tous les gens qui
savent pas écrire
s'ils pensent qu'ils sont pas capables
qui pensent que l on faire des fautes
d'orthographe
ça compte on l'écrit pour soi bien prêt
sauf s'il est on a trouvé assez bonne on
la passera à nos enfants pour qu'ils
sachent pas ce qui nous pose pas de
questions
nos enfants ne le pose pas de questions
sur nos vies pour savoir comment ces
têtes dans notre enquête le chemin qu'on
a fait ça y est
n'est ce pas mais l'on va laisser une
trace a réussi deux beaux livres
alors voilà c'est tout simplement et
c'est une thérapie
patrice mme s'est il tire a pu écrire sa
vie parce que on pense qu on se souvient
de rien on s'assoit
il s'habillait les soutenir surtout avec
des photos des téléphones à sa parenté
alors le premier la première car je
commence confessionnelles et l'ol vont
pouvoir avoir quelques annonceurs les
gens vont où l'on va mettre l'adresse
comment ça fonctionne c'est moi ça les
gens vous écoute qui valent sont
enthousiastes comment on fait 5
avantages qu on a l'adresse
ca c'est très simple ceux qui n'ont pas
d'ordinateur
chaque personne je leur demande chaque
personne qui annote lattara qui adresse
de téléphoner à aux enfants d'une amie
qui n'a pas internet et pour apprendre
les notes sont pas content du tout parlé
là puis la téléphonie à ma mère qui est
tendance
parce que si on est si on ne fait pas ce
collectivement on ne se souvient plus de
rien c'est important que que ça que tu
que le rendu soit pas interrompu sa vie
idyllique
xavi on pense qu'ils m'aviez bien bas et
faut l'écrire
moi j'avais départ un plat qui est ma
mère est à plat puis mon par l'absurde
crois pas que j'avais les jambes
il faut l'écrire même si ces taux sont
bas ce que les jeunes écrivains ou sont
faites par leurs textos pourquoi pas
nous ôte un bon alors écrire au sommet
mme s'éprend sawicki temps avec tous les
remords avec toute l'histoire et tours
qui reculent il meurt sur papier c'est
une délivrance me moi j'étais fâché
quand ma mère et c'est à 80 ans que j'ai
fait mon marché tard vous allez me dire
est que j'aime ça va guéri j'ai compris
maman en écrivant en les cris puis le
secret par jeannette
dix mois je sais pas écrire janette
bertrand elle elle est bonne elle est
capable
moi j'ai pas capables vous dit non non
non l'idée c'est de raconter se raconter
la tradition orale ça peut être ça aussi
oui vous demande après comme moi moi je
suis dyslexique
elle manie moi pas décrire off ou savent
pas capable alors moi j'ai écrit malgré
malgré ma dyslexie parce qu'il y avait
quelqu'un à la fiac copie jamais sans
vous avez des petits enfants demandez
aux petits-enfants demander si votre
texte en dessous la porte de votre
voisine qui est bonne en autographes
pour glee corrigé aînés autant avoir une
peur le réflexe de dire ça intéressera
pas personne parce que c'est important
de connaître ce que ça 4 220 mille
personnes ouah ça réveille personne et
c'est pas fini
janette bertrand non c'est pas fini mais
recevaient l'air en pleine forme
jouer salut je vous envoie toutes nos
salutations à très bientôt plus un bravo
dans ce projet interactif où il a donné
donné c'est meilleur que recevoir
bravo merci merci